we just got to take a little shortcut
through the jungle and we're good
jungles eat people like us in the lost
city the difficulties that we had to
overcome were jumpsuit are you okay
jumpsuit
jumpsuit
yep mountain tip
round tip
we wanted to create the absolute least
comfortable thing that you would choose
to wear especially on a jungle adventure
do i need to be wearing a glitter onesie
sexy we're gonna have to take it through
a river
climb mountainside with it and be in the
ocean the jumpsuit is a character unto
itself
i was uncomfortable in my normal baggy
cargo pants and like tennis shoes that
jumpsuit it was fitted and like the
whole thing with the heels
how's acting
good
i can't imagine what the sequence was
doing to her skin it must have been like
wearing a cheese grater
we wanted something that when you stuck
this in the jungle was going to stand
out how do they keep finding us
basically walking disco ball
i'm going to be talking about the
jumpsuit for the rest of my life but
would i have changed it hell no
oh you're going to put it back together
i don't want to mess up the jumpsuit
it's on loan it was funny it was
inappropriate and it all came about
because
sandy b likes herself a jumpsuit
i like a sparkly jumpsuit
[Music]
[Music]
you